what do you guys think who settles more
men or women guys
okay well it's a really tricky one this
because
um
it's not a matter of settling it's not a
matter of uh like this oh well I'll just
go with this guy you know you you only
get to settle if you have a lot of
choice yeah
and that's that's the reason why I would
say that women probably settle more than
men do because men don't have as much
Choice like some considerable margin
so unless of course they are the you
know the alpha you know most men
um no they don't they don't settle they
have one or two opportunities they they
you know they find somebody that
suits them I think and you know they
don't I don't think their expectations
are as high so so you know you can call
that settling if you like but I think
that because women have a good deal more
choice
I think it depends what you mean by
settling right so like I think men
settle for what they can get like most
most men because because uh like if I
speak to my friends they they only have
they don't get girls coming to them all
the time right so when they do get a
girl it's like well this is all I've got
so I'm I'm gonna try settle so that's
that's what I think and I think because
girls have more Choice it's it's harder
for them to sorry settle in in today's
today's age if you mean like settle like
as in okay this is what I'm gonna settle
for like I'm gonna settle for this type
of woman or this what like type of thing
because some men only get like that
choice yeah what's the difference
between so what specifically you guys
what is the difference between settling
and that's just your level
so the girl because I you said something
like oh she's just gonna go with her
baby daddy because you know even though
he gives her problems but isn't that
just her level because she can't get
anything better well she could maybe
she's just not looking because she's so
comfortable in her situation or maybe
she could sleep up but not lock him down
but also
um I don't know a lot of with the whole
baby mama baby daddy why is there so
much drama like from it could be from
either side I feel like there's always
something like people don't always break
up in the best amicable way well it's
because they didn't plan a family yeah
exactly they said did you just get
pregnant yeah it's not really like a
decision that both of them plan but
there's also a lot of women that try to
trap the man as well which is like he's
not gonna love you just because you have
a child you know well they're paid to do
it if you pay someone to trap people
like trap America she can get child
support for 18 years
not in the UK it's not worth it it's
like it's like it's really low and now
it's decent it's like 15 here something
like that if someone's Rich that could
be a decent chunk of change and if
there's a house involved then you get to
live in it until child's 18. oh really
yeah oh I didn't know that
my husband gets thrown out on the street
oh [ __ ] really I didn't actually know
that that's crazy yeah if kids are
involved right yeah yeah
so what is from the ladies what is a guy
that you would settle for
me
[Music]
um
I feel like if I would settle it would
be more so because of my emotions
um and that would be out of love like if
I genuinely care for that person and you
know sometimes we talk about oh yeah you
know this guy he has so much potential
you know he's going somewhere I feel
like that may be
um a reason for me to settle because of
my emotions oh so it would be like it'd
be like a bum no no you said he's going
somewhere so I'm assuming he's not
somewhere now uh I'm just based off what
you said oh well so you'd be settling
for like a guy that that's not
financially there I'm you're gonna hold
him down
no but I feel as though um the
definition is subjective you know like
personally for me when I say potential I
mean okay someone that is going
somewhere with their their life okay
they have a job or they have a secure
um income but their dreams and
aspirations are a lot larger than what
they have at the moment like for me
personally I would never settle for a
bomb like bummy behavior is no no okay
he's gotta he's gonna have a job I mean
he's got to have like
it needs to be like matching at least
you know you make or higher
a job that he is able to provide for
himself and do things for himself I
don't mean like a bum that's just
sitting on the couch like oh bye honey
you're welcome home
so when you say subtle so what did you
mean when you said like you're gonna
hold him down and he's gonna no I I just
necessarily oh
I just meant in terms of like um holding
that person down I don't believe I said
that because no personally I wouldn't
yeah but um no I just mean in in terms
of like supporting that person with
their aspirations I wouldn't hold that
man down like okay that's not how I was
raised okay
what's the guy that you would settle for
that I would settle for yeah
well I got it outside of four has to be
a guy that has a good job and good money
um is a family man
um
and yeah
okay so that sounds like a catch
that doesn't sound like saddling
like that sounds like give me his number
you know
a man with a job now she said family man
oh yeah okay go ahead remember the job
who likes pets
all right God
um
sure if I could settle because like the
number one important the most important
thing for me is character okay and so
kind of an issue I'm having with dating
is like a date with the intention of
marriage and if I marry then I have to
submit and so I would need somebody in
which I trust their judgment in order to
submit to them so that's like the number
one thing for me and we need to have the
same values which are what
um preferably the same Outlook in terms
of like politics hopefully religion but
it's kind of hard to find
um and somebody that wants a family
mainly
okay I think it's also worth saying that
you know marriage is a partnership very
much a partnership it may be a
partnership you know at the end of the
day if you have two people
um trying to do something they're
they're going to disagree they're they
are absolutely going to disagree so
somebody has to have the casting vote
yeah and
quite often that's the man quite often
it's the woman as well actually but
um you know you need to you need to
build a partnership and practicing
building that partnership in a boyfriend
girlfriend situation is a pretty good
idea not just evaluating them as
somebody who you might attach to
yourself but also
but also can I build something together
with this person can I make a
partnership with them you know in the
real sense
you know when you guys are describing
your partners as well is this someone
that you would marry or someone you date
because I feel like because in my
situation right I was I was just a
teacher so like 23k and I was 10K in
debt right so if I told you those two
things I was a teacher 23k and I was in
debt most of you probably wouldn't like
even give me a chance right and this is
why I like kind of your answer a bit
where you said well as long as there's
like drive or like the idea but I think
the problem is you wouldn't even date
that guy in the first place to find out
if you did have a drive or if he did
have that that's that's how that's how
my dad was with my mom like he he was in
a lot of debt when she first met him
like yo I feel like your situation does
not equal your future like no no I agree
I was just saying like yeah like how do
you see that how do you without being
vain or not vain but like challenging
the profile you can't you can't get that
right you can't for me like
is the more the most important thing is
like morals and like how a person
carries themselves like how you treat
people how you present yourself that is
the top thing for me the money comes
after like the money is not even a major
thing is because we're all out here
chasing goals chasing dreams we're all
not where we want to be so we're all in
our own little journey I'm doing quite
well
speak for yourself
it wasn't overnight I think it's worth
saying that um yes ambition is you know
very likely to be in your shopping list
one of the boxes that you tick so to
speak but the the issue is the
um I'd say feminism has made men less
ambitious in recent years
yeah it's it's
um you know it's put you know if there's
anybody who's who's uh
who's uh has less attention paid to them
um
it's it's young men and and they're not
encouraged to be ambitious the thing
about ambition is you have to have a
vision of what you can do what's
possible in your life
and they're being ignored so you know it
finding an ambitious man at this precise
moment in history is not an easy thing
to do
you know you have to be I'm not saying
it's your responsibility but what I'm
saying is yeah look for a guy who's got
potential even if he doesn't know
exactly where he's going
look for a guy who's got potential and
bring help him to bring that out in
himself you can do that and that's
brilliant I think men need purpose too
and it's hard for them when they don't
have a woman to pursue or show any
interest in them and one out of three
men are either virgins or haven't had
sex in the past year well yeah so I
think there's a large portion of men
that's growing that feels very unseen
and are very lonely and I think and I
think it's like hard to be motivated if
you don't have a woman to work for
absolutely
um ish do you want to show them
so we're gonna watch a video
this video is by poor man's podcast
shout out
um really great Channel you guys should
look him up if you haven't seen his
stuff already he does really great
compilation and reaction videos
um okay so we're gonna look on there
yeah okay
so this is okay here we go
you could put it in the full video
like everyone on the screen yeah oh yeah
minimum but for men y'all we have to
come with a hundred percent we have to
check off every box but as women we have
to be like you know what
he provides
he he he's he's loyal so therefore he
doesn't have to be physically attracted
what what boxes are y'all checking out
let me know what you we try we check off
everything we are smart we provide we're
good wife we're good Mothers we have
good we come from good homes we can cook
we can clean we're good in bed like
everything that we have to mount up to
we do and I feel like as women
unfortunately we have to settle I'm
going to take it in the order that you
said because when you ask a question off
the top usually people respond with
what's off the top okay right your first
things that you listed had nothing to do
with what men want and women what do
y'all want and that's the problem we
want a feminine woman that wants to be
fit that wants to take care of the small
inconveniences in our lives and
reciprocate the value so if I go the
inconveniences in my life so for me for
example I go to work every single day my
wife gets to sleep in if she wants to I
have a trip to Florida in 10 days she's
already booked the trip she's already
booked the flight she's already taken
care of airbnbs I don't have to worry
about that when I get when I sit down
she brings me a warm plate that's
something that I look for in a woman I
don't care about if a woman can provide
why would a man care about if a woman
can provide do you feel like your
household is a typical household that we
see now in 2021 or are we now in a in a
atmosphere where it's both women and men
bringing things to the table as far as
providing for a household you say your
your wife your wife gets to sleep in
okay that is that's really good yeah but
that's not typical that's but that's
because my wife selected me based on my
drive and not my appearance she seen the
vision she's seen where I wanted to go
and she helped me get to that position
she didn't even do that why do we get
called gold diggers do you feel like
your wife with a gold digger because she
looked at your drive she looked at your
ambition she looked at what you could do
for her financially my wife with me
since I was 15. so that in particular
I'm gonna give you that you know because
that's not the typical situation what
I'm trying to get at I don't oh if a
woman is kind of the gold digger if the
man already is solidified and that's
what women want in 2021 and that's why
it don't work out y'all try to go for
men that are already solidified that
look a certain kind of way and then when
it don't work out y'all play dumb look
at it look at Brittany Renner PJ watch
she dealing with PJ Washington oh he
told me this he told me that that don't
matter did he put a ring on that finger
we judge character based off action we
judge characters being married we judge
character based on actions they were
married PJ PJ Watson if anyone was
married yes oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] that up
there but you looking at like situations
like Sierra and future look at their
situation you dealing with a man that's
been around the block he got kids he
ain't been taking care of his kids and
now you want to lay up with him and this
ain't even something that's celebrity
only reason I use celebrities is because
we all know them people I can go to the
hood right now to show you hella
relationships that's messed up because
it's a dude that's a crackhead he got
three or four baby mamas he ain't doing
nothing with his life but because he
looked a certain way all these women
want to lay up with him and date them
based on potential
but when you're talking about potential
are you talking about Will Smith before
he became Will Smith because that's
potential are you talking about Barack
Obama when Michelle Obama held him down
through law school because that's
potential but are you talking about a
dude that's just sexually attractive
that ain't doing nothing with his life
are you hoping that he get it together
one day while he living off of your uh
your refund check I feel like that's
easier said than done like you said you
want women to go you're telling me women
should date based off potential but as
soon as we do that we get called every
negative name in the book if we look at
a man and say hey he has a good job he
can financially provide for me he might
not be the best looking but I look good
we automatically get labeled a gold
digger but you're telling me that's what
we should be going after but I'm but
you're also saying that look at Brittany
Renner she went she went after a guide
that could financially provide for he
for her he might not have been the best
guy but she would talk would you
consider Brittany a gold digger
uh I would consider an opportunist for
sure and I think that her resume shows
that and I think that that's why she's
catching the flag she's catching the
flag because she promoted herself and
branded herself as a woman that would go
after men for a check why can't we go
based off potential and opportunity you
can go based off a potential opportunity
but the problem is y'all not going out
for financial an opportunity y'all going
off a man they're already successful
that's the problem there's nothing wrong
with that you have to look at the age
that we're dating at this point there
are people becoming more successful
younger and younger we're not talking
about these people that are becoming
successful in their 50s and 60s people
are coming becoming millionaires in
their young that's Instagram that's the
difference in perspective men don't
reach Financial potential the peak of
their financial potential until about 55
to 65 years old that's not always true
though it's not always true but see now
we go into the exceptions but you don't
know who I did what if I date the except
we're going to the exception what if I
date the exception but you don't because
if you was day in the acceptance you
would still be with them who said that
not with him okay maybe that's fair okay
basically getting that is women are
looking for the wrong name me one good
King one good conqueror that had one
woman
LeBron
you think LeBron I got one I'm an
athlete I'm an ex-professional athlete
come on let's keep it up you think
LeBron ain't and I'm not even going and
you can't even count Martin Luther King
because he was sleeping around he was
right so what are we talking about any
good man that has already been
established come on let's just keep it
up
didn't we just discuss that if you text
everybody in your phone right now you
you said 100 success rate would sleep
with you that's not the case for average
man do you know that 30 of men will be
virgins by the age of 30 will have never
touched a woman
that means that women have the selective
choice of who they mate with so you have
the responsibility of who Allah who you
allow in your body y'all choosing them
based off of parents that's what I'm
trying to get at when and y'all got the
whole y'all got the whole y'all got a
layout all you got to do as a woman is
okay so for men our burden to society
our burden to humanity is to build
civilizations that's our job whatever
you want I'm gonna provide men build the
microphone build the camera build the
house this is all men this is what we do
we provide you gonna make the face like
we don't do that
this is what we do we provide locally
women have
started things first a lot of the time
but it's okay go ahead the reason why I
feel like it is men because I feel like
men have too many options I feel like
men kind of are at this point like they
find something good
but they're never satisfied
so whenever they feel like something
else come to them that might be a little
bit better Unfortunately they hop on
that and they take that next option so
so when I just said the statistic that
30 of men will be virgins that didn't
like do anything that didn't improve
things that didn't show to you that men
don't by and large have the majority of
the options men get with what men get
with what they can get women get to
choose who they want when it comes to
sexual I feel like virgins could be not
[ __ ] too so no so everybody in your
phone that you get to choose from oh you
could wait till he's done with the
sentence um those are all men that are
in your plethora of people you can be
involved with now it's up for you to
decide whether those men are good
candidates for you to be involved with
now that's your responsibility as a
woman like I said a man's responsibility
is to build civilization in societies a
woman's responsibility is to bring to
bring forth the next generation of
society builders
so I'd like to get everyone's thoughts
on that clip here go ahead so much so
much came out honestly and
um one thing was that
um you know okay oh I'm sorry uh you
know obviously I'm talking from the
perspective of somebody who's uh you
know quite a long way from his puberty
so you know I've seen the dating
uh landscape changed quite dramatically
in my life and one or two things kind of
came up one of the things was that
and not so much in the UK but certainly
in America it was
you didn't date somebody unless your dad
had given in the once over
you know you just didn't
maybe you disagree but are you saying
that Sierra's Dad wouldn't have approved
a future
I don't know maybe he would who knows
but but no I mean the
in the states it was like the first
thing that happened there was a a Trope
of you know the boyfriend knocking on
the front door and the father opened uh
you know
um answering it
and you know she's agonizing over or I
need to make all these choices well the
dad used to do the first level of
filtering
you know a few a couple of decades ago
there was also the fact that it's like
actually do you know what the idea of a
woman
finding a man's body attractive is
relatively new as well I mean I remember
I don't know when I was in my early 20s
maybe when women started started going
oh he's got a nice bum before that it
was out of no
importance whatsoever whether a guy was
whether a guy's body was sexually
attractive or not
so like so did girls just not care about
looks at all it was more about character
it was much more about because women are
supposed to be the attractive ones yes
sir it's really supposed to be the most
yeah let's face it we're not actually I
mean you know maybe 0.5 of men is really
actually women find 80 of men
unattractive yeah yeah not just okay
unattractive yeah yeah yeah so yeah I
mean that you know pretty much pans out
yeah but like just two two years that
like all the people that I know in
relationships have all been from like in
work a friend of a friend stuff like
that the Tinder thing just hasn't worked
for guys by the way the Tinder thing
just hasn't worked actually even my
female friends well yeah women only
swipe right like five to fifteen percent
of the time on dating apps and that's
the number one way people are meeting
nowadays so the reason that women say
things like men are trash is because
they're all screwing the same ones
absolutely oh not a community you guys
yeah I mean I would say the only thing I
don't agree with that like a lot of it
like made sense the only thing is like
when he said what he looks for in a
woman that the the only thing is like I
do want a female I'm dating to at least
have a shop because if she was 23 and
didn't have a job that would just be a
little bit weird and you you gotta take
the economic like thing in this like the
average wage is like 28 grand right and
and you can't live off that on your own
so usually you expect you and your
partner to have a job so if she doesn't
then order burdens on you so I just
think in modern day you kind of have to
not she doesn't have to be the provider
but you at least want her to bring uh
something I would probably mitigate to
risk a little bit if people are more
successful but I think the point is like
you're not if a girl has a high paying
job you're not like oh that's hot yeah
where if a guy has a high paying job
we're like oh damn yeah yeah so that's
more like a minimum I at least want them
to have a job but I don't care if
they're whatever I think
because I just like interact there
because I think it's worth pointing out
that I mean so for instance
um
I lived in a house with one income my
father's income my mum looked after me
and my brother so she could dedicate all
of her time to us yeah
feminism rolls along all of a sudden
it's better to have a boss than a
husband you know that was basically the
message of feminism isn't it and uh and
basically
uh families had two incomes
and the house prices and prices of
everything else Rose to accommodate that
they got dinkies double income no kids
yet which were like the uh the you know
newly married couple and then and then
essentially everything everything became
more difficult because all of a sudden
you needed two income you needed two
incomes to be able to get a mortgage you
needed two incomes to be able to afford
a holiday
um and that was the sum total of the
effect of of feminism other than the
fact that of course the government got
twice as much tax tax money
you know and the children got neglected
as a result
I think it also depends on the lifestyle
you want too like if you want to live in
the city like London yes two incomes is
necessary but if you want to live in a
rural side where the home prices are
significantly cheaper if perhaps you
want to homeschool your children grow
your own food I think it's definitely
possible depending on what your
priorities are
um but yeah it depends on the couple as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible